bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi sur notre antenne
l'allocution en séance publique du
nouveau président du sénat jean pierre
bel
il devrait présenter les grandes
orientations de sa politique pour les
trois prochaines années à venir
cette allocution au sera suivie d'un
débat préalable au prochain conseil
européen pour en parler j'accueille à
mes côtés simon sutour sénateur
socialiste et nouveau président de la
commission des affaires européennes
bonjour bonjour alors peut-être en un
mot sur l'élection de jean pierre bel et
le contrat de gouvernance qu'il a mis en
place la semaine dernière
fallait-il donner une commission à la
droite les communistes ont estimé que
c'était son premier faux pas bon je
pense pas je pense que c'est quelque
chose de bien d'avoir une assemblée où
l'opposition a dirigé la commission des
finances ce qui permet un regard plus
acéré de l'opposition qui joue ainsi son
rôle
c'est ce qui se passe à l'assemblée
nationale je crois que c'est bien que ça
se passe au sénat et c'est bien que sur
jean pierre bel qui les fait c'est
regrettable que cela n'ait pas été fait
avant
très bien alors en ce qui concerne de ce
débat préalable au prochain conseil
européen
le sommet a été reporté ce que c'est une
bonne chose de reporter ce sommet pour
finalement que la zone euro se mettent
d'accord sur les mesures à prendre
c'est toujours un peu inquiétant lorsque
l'on reporte un sommet puisque cela veut
dire qu'il ya des difficultés qu'il faut
surmonter mais bon c'est un report d'une
semaine donc je pense que finalement on
arrivera
une bonne solution alors parmi les
enjeux de ce prochain sommet européen il
ya la question de la grèce aujourd'hui
est ce que il faut continuer à renflouer
la grèce où est ce que il faut bien
qu'elle sorte de la zone euro je pense
pas qu'il faille y présenter le problème
cette manière nous avons la zone euro
dans la grèce fait partie et nous sommes
devront être effectives main solidaire
dans des membres de l'union européenne
qui est membre de la zone euro
alors ensuite il ya également la
question de la recapitalisation des
banques
ce week end lors d'une rencontre entre
nicolas sarkozy angela merkel et bien
les deux chefs d'état se sont prononcés
pour une recapitalisation est ce que
c'est une mesure qu'il faut prendre
rapidement pour rassurer les marchés
moi je ne sais pas j'ai l'impression que
l'on court après les marchés que l'on ne
les rassure jamais et qu'il ya beaucoup
de réunions au niveau européen avec au
bout du compte on n'arrive jamais à des
solutions peut-être qu'il faudrait faire
plus simple et plus efficace
ok pour vous posez vous pour les banques
qui sont quand même fragilisé on a vu le
démantèlement de dexia
c'est que les banques sont quand même
dans une situation fragile les banques
sont dans une situation fragile mais si
l'économie de manière plus large qui est
fragile je pense que ce qui est
important ce serait la relance de
l'économie et la relance de la
croissance
comment on relance la croissance comment
relancer l'économie peut-être un l'achat
sur la consommation
alors il y a également bien le vote
aujourd'hui au parlement de la slovaquie
pour renforcer le fonds européen de
stabilité financière c'est le dernier le
pays qui doit de donner son accord
si la slovaquie ne vote pas qu'est ce
qu'il se passe ce sera ennuyeux mais sur
les optimistes je pense que la slovaquie
vente aura alors une dernière question
aussi mont sutton vous succéder à jean
bizet à la tête de la commission aux
affaires européennes sur quels dossiers
comptez-vous faire avancer la commission
vont bien entendu
sur la crise économique nous allons nous
en occuper puisqu'au niveau européen
c'est aujourd'hui le sujet majeur mais
nous sommes aussi en période de
préparation budgétaire pour l'agenda
2020 et ça sera notre préoccupation
principale dans l'année qui vient en
particulier
moi je suis un ardent défenseur de la
politique régionale dans la politique de
cohésion des régions intermédiaires et
ça se rende mes axford action en tant
que président de cette commission
eh bien merci simon sutour d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je vous laisse
regagné l'hémicycle du sénat où vous le
savez vous allez pouvoir suivre dans un
premier temps l'allocution de jean
pierre bel
et puis ensuite ce débat préalable au
conseil européen très bonne séance à
tous la science est reprise
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le 25 septembre dernier les grands
électeurs nous devons adresser un
message fort ce message nous l'avons
entendu un intérêt nouveau pour le sénat
est né dans le pays à nous en
conséquence de ne pas décevoir cette
attente de ne pas trahir cet espoir nous
devons faire vivre le changement au
sénat nous voulons un sénat ancré dans
son temps et tournée vers l'avenir
un sénat qui privilégie le débat à
l'affrontement
le dialogue au passage en force au sénat
qui n'est pas fermé sur lui-même mais
ouvert sur la société et ses nouvelles
aspirations passé n'a respecté dans son
rôle de législateur et de contrôleurs de
l'action de l'exécutif la majorité
assumera sa mission et l'opposition sera
respectée
je veux souligner à ce propos le
caractère positif des contacts noués
avec les présidents de groupe pour
mettre en place la bonne gouvernance de
notre assemblée le dialogue entre le
gouvernement et le parlement mais aussi
entre les deux assemblées sont des
facteurs décisifs dans la recherche ou
un bicamérisme assumer et équilibrée
c'est un élément clé dans un contexte
rendu
difficile par la crise à cet égard j'ai
rencontré la semaine dernière le
président de l'assemblée nationale
bernard accoyer pour un premier
entretien constructif
nous avons décidé de nous voir
régulièrement dans le même état d'esprit
pour permettre la bonne marche des
assemblées parlementaires
chers collègues je veux que notre
assemblée soit confortée dans ses
prérogatives restaurer dans son rôle de
représentant des élus locaux et des
territoires rénové dans son mode de
fonctionnement
je vais tout d'abord que le sénat soit
confortée dans ses prérogatives temps
législatives que de contrôler le sénat
devra d'abord être particulièrement
attentifs à la qualité et à la nécessité
de la loi la loi nécessaire
ce n'est pas la loi faits divers le
gouvernement ne dispose plus que de la
moitié du temps parlementaire
il doit en tirer toutes les conséquences
et éviter de surcharger notre ordre du
jour de projets de loi émotionnels ou de
circonstance nos collectivités sont
submergés vous le savez de normes
coûteuses souvent inutiles voire
inapplicable il faut mettre un frein à
cette évolution
c'est pourquoi je propose que le sénat
exactement c'est pourquoi je propose que
le sénat débattent des propositions de
loi de simplification élaboré en
concertation avec des associations
d'élus locaux pour alléger et stabiliser
les normes qui pèsent sur les
collectivités territoriales
ainsi la sécurité juridique se rappelle
renforcer l'équilibré des institutions
appelle un autre
un usage parcimonieux de la procédure
accélérée et du dernier mot à
l'assemblée nationale que monsieur le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
sera parfois tenté sous l'amicale
pression des députés de la majorité de
demande et faire vivre la navette
parlementaire et ne pas décider
a priori d'entraver le dialogue est
bicaméral
c'est assumer le débat démocratique dans
le souci de mieux organiser notre
travail et d'en améliorer la qualité
et c'est une question de principe je
demande au gouvernement de nous
communiquer un calendrier prévisionnel
semestriels cet effort de programmation
interne il faudra bien évidemment nous
l'appliquer à nous-mêmes
je m'adresse particulièrement aux
présidents de groupes et de commissions
qu'ils connaissent bien ces contraintes
je souhaite ensuite que le sénat se
saisissent pleinement de ses pouvoirs
d'investigation de contrôle et
d'évaluation le contrôle et l'évaluation
des politiques publiques doivent être
ambitieux abriter des pressions des
lobbys et des groupes d'intérêts car les
conflits d'intérêts sont elles
compatibles avec une démocratie moderne
ils sont le contraire d'une république
exemplaire dans le cadre des débats à
venir sur le projet de loi relatif à la
déontologie et à la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts dans la vie publique
il me paraît indispensable que le
conflit d'intérêts soient définies
précisément
de même nos travaux devront conduire à
étendre les préconisations du rapport de
la commission de réflexion pour la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts n'est
ce pas cher jean léonce dupont dans la
vie publique à tous les décideurs
publics y compris aux élus y compris à
nous parlementaires car l'or car nous
devons d'abord nous appliquer à
nous-mêmes ce que nous prenons pour nos
concitoyens
le sénat doit être à l'écouté des
attentes d'un concitoyen est en capacité
de faire évoluer les administrations il
doit s'affirmer comme un contrôleur
exigeant protecteur des citoyens et des
usagers
cela s'inscrit pleinement dans sa
tradition historique de défenseurs des
libertés publiques
enfin le sénat doit aussi s'adapter dans
son organisation aux évolutions
profondes de notre société notamment en
matière de développement durable
l'urgence c'est la mutation écologique
s'impose à nous paul vergès nous l'a
rappelé dans son beau discours lors de
notre séance d'installation
nous devons aujourd'hui les prendre en
compte dans nos travaux et dans nos
propositions
notre souci a défait
doit être l'adaptation permanente du
sénat aux défis de son temps
c'est dans cet esprit que je proposerai
mais après une large concertation la
création de deux nouvelles commissions
comme la constitution le permet depuis
la révision de 2008
et comme l'a déjà fait l'assemblée
nationale je propose aussi comme je l'aï
indiqué ici même dès mon premier
discours en tant que président du sénat
la création d'une délégation à
l'outre-mer ainsi les situations et des
défis spécifiques de l'outre-mer seront
ils davantage prise en compte et leurs
atouts pleinement valorisé je souhaite
ensuite sénart restaurer dans son rôle
de représentant des élus locaux
il est indispensable indispensable de
rendre nos collectivités plus fortes
dans une france plus efficace nous
savons tous ce mécénat est
constitutionnellement le représentant
des collectivités territoriales il doit
être au coeur du dialogue restaurée
entre l'état et les collectivités
locales
la réforme territoriale doit être
abrogée et entièrement repensé une
réforme est à l'évidence nécessaire et
je les ai entendus dans de nombreux
endroits mais celle ci je crois et aller
dans le mauvais sens elle s'est
accompagnée d'une révision générale des
politiques publiques dont on a vu des
effets dévastateurs dans nos territoires
elle s'est traduite par une réforme des
services de l'état inefficace illisible
pour nos citoyens est préjudiciable pour
les collectivités locales
la recentralisation est une régression
la décentralisation doit reprendre sa
marche en avant
je vous propose que le sénat joue un
rôle de premier plan dans cette relance
de la décentralisation
j'ai même eu le sentiment en fin de
semaine dernière que quelque chose avait
changé en ce domaine lors de mon premier
entretien avec le premier ministre
je lui ai demandé de revoir le
calendrier de la réforme de
l'intercommunalité françois fillon a
indiqué je le cite que la procédure ne
sera menée à son terme que lorsqu'une
majorité claire des élus concernés se
dégagera le gouvernement prend donc
enfin conscience que l'on ne peut pas
sur cette question si sensible passer en
force
ceci imposera de corriger la loi
mais il faut bien entendu aller plus
loin dès cet hiver
des états généraux des territoires des
élus locaux pourraient être organisées
par le sénat il réunirait toutes les
associations d'élus et les acteurs
locaux
majorité et opposition pourront si elles
le souhaitent ils prendre toute leur
part il s'agira de dresser un constat de
la situation et d'esquisser des
perspectives d'avenir
ces états généraux permettront de
définir les priorités d'une relance de
la décentralisation pour renforcer les
libertés les solidarités locales
ainsi la nouvelle décentralisation
pourra être rapidement engagées dès le
début de la prochaine législature à
l'initiative et avec les mots du sénat
je souhaite que le sénat réfléchit c'est
dans ce cadre à un nouveau pacte
financier entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
caractérisé par le retour au respect de
l'autonomie fiscale
le financement national de l'allocation
de solidarité la création de dispositifs
de péréquation adapté le sénat doit
enfin formulé des propositions
novatrices sur la place des services
publics notamment en milieu rural et
dans les territoires urbains en
difficulté il doit proposer de s'engager
sur la voie d'un aménagement équilibré
du territoire
l'objectif est de garantir un accès
équitable des citoyens au service public
et d'assurer la réduction des inégalités
territoriales
de même il faut redéfinir les missions
et l'organisation de l'état dans les
territoires et conforter le soutien
juridique et technique apportée aux
communes en matière de conseil et
d'ingénierie technique
en bref le sénat devra être
l'inspirateur et le garant de cette
nouvelle gouvernance des territoires et
de ce nouveau pacte de confiance entre
l'état et les élus locaux
je souhaite enfin senna rénové dans son
mode de fonctionnement interne
c'est le souhait de l'ensemble de la
majorité dans sa diversité
vous le savez composée de socialistes de
communistes de radicaux de gauche des
écologistes et d'autre et c'est un
souhait je le crois partagée sur tous
les bancs de notre assemblée
la nouvelle gouvernance mise en place
par nos votes dans les commissions se
caractérise par la volonté de donner sa
juste place à chaque groupe et d'abord
par le respect de l'opposition
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que nous
avons souhaité que la commission des
finances soit présidée par l de même
pour respecter cette diversité à
laquelle nous sommes tous attachés
je vous proposerai de fixer à dix le
nombre de sénateurs nécessaires pour
créer un groupe de façon à traduire
justement l'expression politique de
notre assemblée
la rénovation du sénat doit être aussi
visible nous connaissons le rôle qu'a
joué à ce propos public sénat il nous
faudra réfléchir ensemble aux moyens de
mieux faire comprendre nos concitoyens
l'ensemble du processus d'élaboration de
la loi et du travail parlementaire
enfin l'image de notre institution reste
hélas encore trop dégradée et le train
de vie du sénat trop souvent stigmatisé
notamment par la presse
il est nécessaire d'aller vers un sénat
que je qualifierais de plus modestes et
nous ne devons craindre aucun regard
extérieur notamment celui de la cour des
comptes sous réserve
naturellement que les principes
inhérents à la séparation des pouvoirs
soit respectée on ne manage pas une
institution publique comme une
entreprise
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
une gestion rigoureuse surtout dans ces
temps de crise et de concret et de
contraintes financières
le bureau du sénat avait envisagé lors
de sa dernière réunion
une augmentation du budget correspondant
à l'inflation
cela n'est plus possible aujourd'hui nos
efforts doivent aller au delà
non seulement notre budget ne doit pas
augmenter en valeur mais je demande pour
l'an prochain
la préparation d'un budget réduit en
volume pour cela je souhaite engager dès
maintenant une révision complète du
programme très important de travaux qui
avait été envisagé nous en tiendrons aux
seuls travaux strictement nécessaire à
l'entretien et la préservation de ce
magnifique patrimoine
de même nous avons à nous pencher sur
les critiques qui ont été émises à
l'égard de notre fonctionnement et vous
l'avez souvent entendu pourquoi ne pas
le dire à l'égard des sénateurs eux
mêmes nous ne pouvons refuser d'aborder
ce sujet un groupe de travail devra
rapidement s'en saisir il aura à
s'exprimer certes sans tabou et sans
frilosité mais sans tomber non plus dans
la démagogie ou je ne sais quel
emballement futile médiatique
nous travaillerons dans la sérénité et
sans céder à la pression
chaque collègue le sénat a été au rendez
vous de l'alternance
il se doit d'être au rendez vous du
changement
nous avons un intérêt commun à faire
vivre nos débats notre pluralisme
assumer nos divergences dans le respect
des uns et des autres cela concerne
également nos rapports avec le
gouvernement que je souhaite confiant
transparent et apaisé
au delà de nos engagements respectifs
c'est le souci de l'intérêt général et
du bien commun qui nous anime la
république a le droit d'attendre du
sénat et de chacun d'entre nous de se
retrouver lorsque l'intérêt supérieur
l'exigent être le président de tous les
sénateurs dans un sénat conforter
rénover les respecter c'est le rôle que
je compte assumer
avec votre concours et avec votre aide
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
préalable du conseil européen du 23
octobre 2011
pour lui
oh
oui
chers collègues en vous demandant de
bien vouloir prendre place
donc j'ai indiqué que l'ordre du jour
appelait le débat préalable au conseil
européen qui vous le savez devait avoir
lieu le 13 octobre qui se déroule le 17
octobre pardon et qui se dévouent
déroulera le 23 octobre dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur jean leonetti
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission affaires
européennes monsieur le président de la
commission affaires économiques dames le
rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
je tenais avant tout au nom de l'esprit
républicain qui nous anime tous à
apporter mes félicitations au président
du sénat jean-pierre bel ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble des sénateurs qui viennent
d'être élus et qui viennent d'accéder à
des responsabilités vous le savez les
conseils européens sont des rendez vous
majeurs ils sont des rendez vous majeurs
pour la france ils sont des rendez vous
majeur pour l'europe
il définit les grandes orientations de
la politique européenne et permettent de
prendre au plus haut niveau des
décisions nécessaires souvent
courageuses aujourd'hui indispensable
dans les temps bouleversée que nous
vivons le conseil des 23 et 24 octobre
prend un sens particulier nous le savons
tous tout le sentons tous
l'europe est un tournant de son histoire
le monde est un tournant de son histoire
je vois dans ce qu'on appelle la crise
la disparition d'un monde ancien et
cette période intermédiaire qui va
permettre l'élaboration et la
construction d'un monde nouveau et donc
dans ces périodes de crises multiples on
peut toujours avoir
l'angoissé la peur de l'avenir on peut
aussi considérer que ce sont des moments
d'opportunités des moments d'espoir et
des moments d'action l'europe sortira de
la période actuelle plus intégré plus
forte grâce à un nouvel équilibre que
nous devrions mettre en place entre la
discipline budgétaire et la solidarité
indispensable entre la gestion
rigoureuse et la croissance les débats
du conseil européen seront centrés vous
le savez sur trois thématiques
la gouvernance économique et la
croissance de demain le g20 sein duquel
la france et l'europe
un message fort à donner au monde et le
réchauffement climatique et la
conférence de durban sur la zone euro la
gouvernance économique et la croissance
vous le savez le 21 juillet les chefs
d'états et de gouvernements ont pris des
décisions importantes
le fonds européen de stabilité
financière s'est trouvée renforcée
assouplies capable d'intervenir dès
désormais sur des rachats de dette sur
la recapitalisation d'un certain nombre
de banques et sur les marchés
secondaires
cette situation permet une réactivité
indispensable dans la période que nous
connaissons et nous sommes en train de
créer donc un véritable fonds monétaire
européen
la gouvernance économique a également
progressé avec l'adoption le 28
septembre par le parlement européen et
le 4 octobre par le conseil de ce qu'on
appelle le paquet de gouvernance
économique en anglais et vous
m'excuserez six pack
cette avancée majeure ou la broye à une
autre modèle de gouvernance économique
avec une surveillance et avec une aile
une alliance assez équilibrée entre la
vigilance et la prévention et la
correction des possibles anomalies
macroéconomique ce pacte de stabilité et
croisent et que de croissance a donc
passer à une étape supplémentaire et
elle est un des outils essentiels pour
la gouvernance économique de demain je
vous le dis à titre personnel mais parce
que c'est au fond de ma conviction nous
devons aller plus vite et plus loin
renforcer le pilotage de la zone euro et
le président du conseil fera connaître
ses propositions dans les jours qui
viennent
alors que la france et l'allemagne vous
le savez ont pour leur part appelé ce
dimanche qu'elle souhaitait aller plus
loin dans l'intégration économique de la
zone
elle avait demandé le 16 août que soit
reconnu le rôle spécifique des chefs
d'état de gouvernement la présidence
stable a été confié à herman van rompuy
et il faudrait enfin renforcer des
moyens dont disposent les minutes de
file des finances avec des rencontres
régulières au niveau des chefs d un
renforcement des moyens du comité
économique et financier et de la working
group doivent donc être envisagée j'ose
le mot devant vous nous devons passer un
fédéralisme économique sous peine de
voir l'europe se désintégrer par les
attaques des spéculateurs financiers
cette gouvernance économique n'aura de
sens que s'il est associé à une
politique de croissance forte
celle ci sera bien sûr largement
débattue au prochain conseil et trois
axes majeurs définissent aujourd'hui
notre politique de soutien à la
croissance au niveau européen
approfondir le marché intérieur renforcé
notre politique industrielle et imposer
une concurrence mondiale
loyal vous le savez nous disposons
disposons du plus grand marché du monde
500 millions d'européens
un pib cumulé annuel de 12 mille
milliards d'euros l'acte pour le marché
unique et ses douze trios étaient
proposées par le commissaire michel
barnier
en avril dernier nous permettra
d'approfondir pour en tirer tout le
potentiel
nous soutenons un brevet unitaire
nous travaillons sur l'assiette commune
consolidée pour l'impôt sur les sociétés
qui devraient permettre de réduire là
aussi défragmentation dans l'économie
que nous trouvons au niveau de la zone
euro la france vous le savez se bat
aussi pour obtenir une politique
industrielle forte
cette compétitivité doit se baser sur
l'innovation les infrastructures et elle
doit accompagner bien sûr les politiques
sectorielles la communication sur la
politique industrielle d'octobre 2010 va
dans ce sens nous devons nous concentrer
sur les secteurs d'avenir secteur de
l'espace avec vidéos et le programme
européen de surveillance terre jms le
numérique ou les grands champions
européenne doit pouvoir émerger dans une
concurrence mondiale de plus en plus
difficile et enfin les technologies
vertes
enfin c'est une revendication française
que l'on appelle d'un terme peut-être
impropre le principe de réciprocité que
nous voulons imposer à l'ensemble du
monde
comment l'europe pourrait-elle donner
des règlements si contraignant sur le
plan écologique sur le plan social sur
le plan normatif et se trouvait dans une
concurrence déloyale vis-à-vis d'autres
pays qui pourraient pénétrer ce marché
sans esprit de réciprocité
il en va de la préservation de notre
économie et de notre modèle et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je veux dire devant
vous de manière très claire qui ne
s'agit en aucune façon d'une forme de
protectionnisme
il s'agit au contraire d'un modèle
incitatif à imposer à l'ensemble du
monde
cet instrument de réciprocité est
indispensable puisque en 2009 ceci
représentait 2088 milliards d'euros en
europe donc 15% était ouvert aux acteurs
étrangers contre 7 seulement 3% aux
etats-unis et 0 9 % au canada et le
chiffre n'est même pas cumulables au
deuxième après la première virgule pour
la chine
comment peut-on accepter que aidées par
l'état la chine puisse construire avec
un dumping social négatif des autoroutes
en pologne et arrêter le chantier au
détriment de toute possibilité de
concurrence
la france continuera donc à peser tout
son poids au conseil pour que ce
principe de réciprocité soit mis en
oeuvre dans toutes les politiques
européennes sur le g20
la france s'est fixé des objectifs
ambitieux el al à la présidence du g20
c'est une présidence européenne
nos objectifs retour à la croissance
redressement des finances et stabilité
du système financier le conseil européen
sera doublement décisif pour préparer le
sommet de cannes d'abord
si l'europe n'a pas réglé d'ici le
sommet de cannes
et d'ici le g20 l'ensemble des problèmes
de la zone euro et de l'europe
il se trouvera dans une situation où
nous aurons un g20 de la dette mais un
g20 de la dette de la zone euro et nous
serons ceux qui porteront la
responsabilité et en même temps qui
seront désignés par l'ensemble du monde
comme les responsables de la récession
et des difficultés que rencontre
l'ensemble du monde les états européens
doivent donc définir lors du conseil les
positions de l'union européenne réforme
du système monétaire international avec
un certain nombre d'avancées en
particulier sur la gestion des flux
financiers progrès effectués en matière
de régulation financière
avec l'extension du bâle iii et son
anticipation dimension sociale de la
mondialisation
comment pourrait-on considérer que le
monde l'europe ne parlerait que
d'économie et de finance et n'aurait pas
la capacité d'établir un socle
indispensable de protection sociale
envers les plus vulnérables et en
particulier envers la jeunesse
enfin le domaine agricole et est un
domaine où la présidence française a
marqué son impulsion
d'une part parce que il faut prévenir
les crises agricoles et d'autre part
parce qu'il faut mais une meilleure
transparence de l'ensemble des stocks
qui permettent justement de préventes de
prévenir l'ensemble de ses difficultés
enfin le développement particulièrement
la sécurité alimentaire et les
infrastructures est un des éléments sur
lequel la france souhaite que ce sujet
soit abordé
je voudrais aborder très brièvement et
nous le ferons pas ultérieurement si
vous le souhaitez le problème la
taxation des transactions financières
on en parle depuis 20 ans il est temps
de la mettre en oeuvre et il est temps
d'accepter de la mettre en oeuvre sans
qu'elle soit universel si les états unis
n'y participent pas il faudra le faire
au niveau de l'europe
et si les seuls pionniers sont dans la
zone euro
parce que la grande bretagne ne souhaite
pas y participer il faudra bien avancé
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un bon tempo et
en impôts qui a une assiette très large
et un taux très faible et on entend
parler d'un taux qui pourrait être à
0,005
croyez-vous franchement que si nous
avions ce tour on aurait un déplacement
des place financière de francfort hong
kong ou de paris à londres
je crois qu'il faut avancer dans ce
domaine parce que il y va aussi d'une
certaine considération morale considérer
que la transaction financière qui
n'apporte rien à l'économie réelle
rien à l'humain ne puisse pas être taxés
et que cette taxation ne puisse pas
venir en aide
un développement et à l'europe c'est une
conception erronée et même s'est tourné
le dos à ce que nous croyons et à ce que
nous croyons pour l'europe c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président de la
république a souhaité avec la
chancelière que cet élément soit ébauché
est envisagée pour le g20 et il en sera
donc ainsi le réchauffement climatique
et la conférence de durban est aussi une
préoccupation française est une
préoccupation européenne l'europe a
toujours assumé assurer une politique
volontariste dans ce domaine le
président de la république l'a manifesté
sur le plan national
nous nous souvenons du grenelle de
l'environnement et sur le plan européen
le paquet énergie climat
le 20 20 20 20 % d'économies
renouvelables 20% de moins de gaz à
effet de serre 20 % de meilleure
efficience
sur le plan de l'énergie ces trois
éléments à objectifs 2020 ne peuvent pas
être autre chose que un coup d'épée dans
l'eau
l'europe c'est 11 % des émissions
si nous faisons seule cette action forte
nous pénaliserons nos entreprises et
nous n'aurons pas d'efficacité sur le
plan international sur le plan
écologique
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons qu'après les règles du kyoto
qui expire en 2012
d'urban constitue un moment capital pour
préparer l'après kyoto
il convient bien entendu de donner un
contenu opérationnel aux accords de
cancun notamment le mécanisme de suivi
des engagements et la mise en place du
fonds vert et des financements innovants
il s'agit aussi bien sûr de évoqué le
futur système de réduction des gaz à des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et de
faire en sorte qu'on évolue vers un
système qui soit claire contraignant et
universel répondre à ce défi est vital
il est il va là non pas de l'économie
générale il n'y va pas non pas de les
équilibres socio-économiques
il y va de l'avenir de la planète vous
le voyez dans la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons l'europe n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'avancer
l'europe n'a pas d'autre choix que de
franchir une étape une étape décisive
qui nous permettra justement de
valoriser et de prôner les valeurs qui
sont les valeurs européennes de
solidarité de liberté de démocratie
merci merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à présent à monsieur simon
sutour président de la commission des
affaires européennes pour huit minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
vous tout d'abord vous dire toute ma
satisfaction que le premier débat de
notre nouveau sénat soit un débat
européenne je voudrais aussi vous dire
toute ma satisfaction que ce débat ait
lieu dans l'hémicycle ce qui parfois
avait été contestée on parle même de
petites et mystique mais ce n'est pas
l'hémicycle
et puis l'horaire est particulièrement
satisfaisant nous avions plutôt
l'habitude d'être relégués très tard en
fin de soirée dans plusieurs motifs de
satisfaction monsieur le président il y
à un ordre du jour théorique du prochain
conseil européen arrêté depuis plus d'un
mois
mais nul doute que le sujet principal
sera une fois de plus la crise
financière qui ne cesse de rebondir
personne ne reprochera au conseil
européen bien au contraire donner
priorité à cette question qui domine
l'actualité
mais cette situation montre que l'europe
ne parvienne pas à être maîtresse de son
destin
la crise financière est partie des états
unis elle sait communiquer à l'europe
puis elle est devenue une crise des
dettes souveraines dans l'europe est
l'épicentre l'europe réagit plus vite
qu'à la magie est le parent au plus
pressé et des décisions présentées comme
suffisantes sont remises en question
avant même d'être en vigueur le plan
adopté le 21 juillet dernier vient à
peine d'être approuvé par tous les
parlements concerné il ya encore un
parlement qui qui se prononce au moment
où je m'exprime et déjà il est question
de nouvelles mesures pour soutenir les
banques pour transformer le rôle du
fonds européen de stabilité financière
il est clair que les décisions prises en
commun ne parviennent pas à recréer
durablement la confiance
il manque à l'europe une force
d'entraînement un centre politique
clairement identifiés qui donne le
sentiment qu'on sait où on va et qu'il
ya une cohérence entre ce qui est
approuvé à bruxelles
et ce qui met mis en oeuvre par les
états qui peut aujourd'hui véritablement
parler au nom de la zone euro pour
monsieur barroso c'est la commission
sous le contrôle du parlement
opm qui doit être le véritable
gouvernement économique de l'eurozone
mais cette revendication se heurte au
fait que la commission et le parlement
représentent collectivement les 27 pays
membres dont 17 seulement appartiennent
à la zone euro
il faudrait une capacité de décision
propre à l'eurozone
aujourd'hui la seule qui existe et celle
de la bce
une autre solution possible serait celle
préconisée par l'accord franco-allemand
du 16 août dernier un gouvernement
économique qui serait la réunion des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de la
zone euro avec la même résidence que le
conseil européen
c'est une solution qui n'est peut-être
pas idéal mais qui al'avantage d'être
immédiatement réalisable et d'être
adaptée à la situation spécifique de
l'eurozone cependant cependant depuis
l'annnonce du 16 août
on attend toujours que cette solution se
confirme et se concrétise
j'ajouterai qu'on ne voit pas non plus
quel est le fil conducteur des décisions
le 21 juillet on nous a expliqué que le
secteur privé c'est-à-dire les banques
devaient participer au sauvetage de la
grèce en acceptant une décote sur les
titres de la dette grecque mais aussi en
achetant de nouveaux titres lorsque les
actuels viendrait à échéance
maintenant on nous explique qu'il faut
recapitaliser les banques européennes
notamment parce qu'elles ont fragilisé
par la possession de titres de dette
publique
il est difficile de trouver une
cohérence entre ses priorités
successives de même les experts annoncé
à la fin du mois dernier qu'il y avait
urgence que la grèce allait faire défaut
début octobre
et maintenant on nous annonce qu'on peut
attendre encore avant d'accorder les fon
alors même que la situation budgétaire
de la grèce continue à se détériorer les
rumeurs et les annonces se succèdent
est ce que les citoyens européens en
retire c'est un sentiment de confusion
et d'absence de perspectives conduisant
à un pessimisme de plus en plus
profondes la seule chose qui était
clairement décidés par l'union
c'est le durcissement du pacte de
stabilité avec notamment des sanctions
plus automatiques
auparavant pour les états en déficit
excessif lorsque cette question a été
abordée au sein de notre commission des
affaires européennes et je prends à
témoin jean bizet nous avons été
nombreux à être sceptique sur ce
renforcement du volet répressif
face à une situation de surendettement
la priorité doit elle ètre d'infliger
une amende ou des amendes
le renforcement du volet préventif du
pacte est un aspect plus intéressant
avec notamment l'idée qu'il vaut mieux
coordonner les politiques budgétaires et
corrigée en temps utile des
déséquilibres macroéconomiques
mais la véritable prévention me
semble-t-il ce serait de redonner à
l'europe des perspectives de croissance
au lieu d'annoncer uniquement toujours
plus d'austérité et de rigueur
monsieur le ministre je sais que votre
spécialité et la cardiologie plutôt que
la psychanalyse mais je voudrais
néanmoins vous rappeler une histoire que
freud raconte un petit ouvrage intitulé
malaise dans la civilisation
il s'agit de l'histoire d'un paysan
havard qui chaque jour donne un petit
peu moins à manger à ceux nan là ne
finit bien évidemment par mourir et le
paysan ne comprends pas cette fin
brutale
il me semble que nous avons tendance à
faire la même chose aujourd'hui nous
prenons partout en europe des mesures
d'austérité la croissance diminue les
recettes fiscales baissent et pour
arriver à réduire quand même les
déficits nous prenons des mesures
d'austérité supplémentaires
on ne voit pas le bout de cette spirale
pourtant lorsque le pacte de stabilité
avait été conclu en 1998 il avait été
rebaptisée à la demande nous notamment
je le rappel du gouvernement français de
l'époque pacte de stabilité et de
croissance
il semble que cette deuxième partie sont
aujourd'hui bien oublié
or si rien n'est fait pour recréer des
anticipations de croissance
il va être extraordinairement difficile
de réduire les déficits accumulés et
nous verrons des tensions de plus en
plus forte au sein de nos sociétés
personne personne ne peut accepter la
réclusion économique pour une génération
et on ne peut pas construire en
assainissement financier sur une
interminable récession la crise est en
train de mettre à l'épreuve la
solidarité européenne
les menaces qui pèsent sur le programme
européen d'aidé aux plus démunis
hansson en sont le triste exemple nous
avons certes qu'il faut prendre en
compte une décision de la cour de
justice
mais franchement voir l'europe
tergiverser lorsqu'il s'agit d' aide
alimentaire aux plus démunis
ce n'est pas seulement une faute sur le
plan social c'est un signal politique
désastreux
nous avons besoin exactement du
contraire
grâce à la crise l'europe a besoin de
plus de solidarité
elle a besoin de plus de solidarité
sociale à l'intérieur des états elle a
besoin de plus de solidarité entre les
régions et c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire que dans le prochain cadre
financier la politique régionale
monsieur le ministre dispose de moyens
suffisants notamment au profit de la
nouvelle catégorie des régions
intermédiaires dans le sénat soutient la
création
je rappelle à cet égard monsieur le
ministre le vote unanime d'une
proposition de résolution par notre
assemblée dans ce sens enfin l'europe a
besoin de plus de solidarité entre les
états
car si nous ne manquerons pas que nous
sommes déterminés à agir dans l'intérêt
commun
nous verrons la spéculation traité les
états comme des dominos et nous finirons
par être tous perdants pour conclure mon
propos je voudrais rappeler une formule
d'un philosophe
j'ai commencé par un psychanalyste je
finis par un philosophe en passant par
interdit aux log d'un philosophe karl
popper qui qui disait les hommes n'ont
pas besoin de certitudes mais ils ont
besoin d'espoir aujourd'hui les
européens ont besoin de regarder au delà
de la crise le conseil européen ne peut
pas leur donner des certitudes mais s'il
doit leur donner des raisons d'espérer
je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur le président et je
veux saluer tous ceux qui vont
s'exprimer à leur qualité nouvelle
aujourd'hui et à ce titre j'appelle
monsieur daniel raoul président de la
commission de l'économie du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le prochain
conseil européen doit aborder la
politique économique extérieure commune
c'est-à-dire les la question des
relations commerciales monétaire et
financière que l'union européenne
entretient avec les pays tiers
au plan multilatéral une conférence
ministérielle est prévue au début du
mois de décembre à genève
que peut-on en attendre le faible espoir
subsistait encore en début d'année
concernant une possible conclusion du
cycle de doha en 2011 mais ils ont ils
se sont évaporés dans ce contexte si
elle se contente de constater le blocage
des négociations et de répéter les
incantations rituel sur la nécessité de
conclure doha
rapidement la ministérielle de décembre
risque d'être à nouveau à ce sommet pour
rien or je ne pense pas qu'on puisse se
satisfaire de cette situation
d'une part en effet le cycle de doha est
ainsi que pour le développement et son
échec s'il n'en dit une handicap que
marginalement les grandes puissances
commerciales constitue en revanche un
sujet d'inquiétude majeur pour les pays
les moins développés
d'autre part le blocage de dos à sa
compagne d'un essor des accords biou
pluri latéraux d'une façon pragmatique
c'est essor du bilatéral est nécessaire
sans doute car en attendant une
hypothétique conclusion du cycle de doha
on ne peut pas indéfiniment remettre à
demain les progrès sur des questions
centrales du commerce contemporains tels
que l'accès aux marchés publics la
protection de la propriété
intellectuelle qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure
ou la coopération réglementaire
cependant il faut être conscient que
s'il bilatérales se développent en lieu
et place du multilatéral cela risque sur
le long terme de saper la légitimité
même de l' approche multilatérale du
commerce
en effet comment l'om c'est son organe
de règlement des différends peuvent-ils
espérer continuer à régler de manière
crédible et efficace le commerce si les
normes du droit commercial international
sur tous les sujets majeurs sont
désormais fixés en dehors du cadre
multilatéral le développement des
accords bilatéraux ne doit donc pas nous
détourner de faire des propositions
nouvelles pour conclure le cycle de doha
et le prochain conseil européen de tels
l'occasion de réfléchir aux moyens
d'avancer dans ce sens on peut en tous
les cas essayer en tout état de cause
l'europe a déjà fait preuve de beaucoup
de bonne volonté pour faciliter la
conclusion du cycle
elle est allée je pense à la limite de
ce qu'elle pouvait concédé notamment
dans le domaine agricole
mais des initiatives concernant les
enjeux et la méthode des négociations
reste sans doute encore envisageable en
particulier en ce qui concerne les
enjeux du cycle en cours
ceux ci se sont focalisés sur le
triptyque soutien à l'agriculture aux
marchés agricoles accès aux marchés pour
les produits non agricoles
la restriction du champ des discussions
assez assez thème était conçu comme un
moyen de ne pas alourdir les
négociations est de faciliter ainsi leur
conclusion je regarde notre collègue
jean bizet c'est bien ce qui nous avait
vendu à l'époque cela pouvait sembler de
bon sens a priori moins il est sujet sur
les tables plus il est facile de trouver
un consensus
en théorie avec le recul on peut se
demander cependant si c'est le cas et au
contraire si ceux ci n'a pas contribué à
gripper la machine
en effet dans le jeu complexe du
donnant-donnant ou du win-win que
constitue des négociations commerciales
internationales
un gain dans un domaine se paye de toute
façon d'une concession dans une
or il n'est pas certain qu'il est
aujourd'hui suffisamment de grain à
moudre à doha pour rendre possible des
concessions nouvelle mutuellement
profitable à toutes les parties
comme je lai indiqué les intérêts
majeurs des grandes puissances
commerciales développés ou émergents de
porte aujourd'hui sur des thèmes situées
en dehors du champ de doigt une
concession sur un des sujets de doha ne
peut par conséquent ne pas être
compensée par une avancée symétrique sur
un autre thème puisque toutes les
avancées intéressantes sont situés en
dehors
il faut donc grillé réfléchir aux moyens
de débloquer le jeu j'en viens
maintenant deuxième volet de la halle de
l'agenda commercial européen à savoir le
volet bilatérales vous le savez nutr le
trimestre qui commence sera riche en
rendez vous important sommet union
européenne chine en novembre sommet
union européenne l'ukraine une union
européenne russie union européenne états
unis en décembre
avec tous ces acteurs importants du
commerce mondial qui sont aussi des
concurrents redoutables pour nous
l'union européenne est aujourd'hui
engagée dans ses négociations
bilatérales
or il faut que le principe de
réciprocité dans l'ouverture des marchés
soit l'objectif premier qui guide ces
négociations ce principe est certes
affiché clairement marais stratégie
européenne depuis avril 2007 par la
commission européenne
on peut se féliciter que l'union
européenne enfin défini sa stratégie
commerciale autour de la notion de
réciprocité
même si on peut regretter le caractère
un peu tardif de sa prise de conscience
cependant maintenant il faut transformer
l'objectif affiché en réalité ils en
valent la croissance et de l'emploi sur
notre continent
pour mémoire rien qu'avec la chine le
déficit commercial de l'union avoisine
actuellement 170 milliards d'euros par
an et même la situation de l'allemagne
n'est guère meilleur que celui de la
france
combien d'emplois perdus représente un
tel déficit commercial
donc nous devons rééquilibrer les
échanges vers plus d'équité dans les
concessions je voudrais simplement
illustrer les enjeux de cette question
avec l'exemple de l'accès aux marchés
publics
l'union européenne a donné accès 85% de
ses marchés publics aux entreprises des
pays tiers dans le cadre de l'accord amp
de l'om sait or nos partenaires sont
beaucoup plus restrictif
les etats unis tout en étant partie
prenante de cet accord exclut certains
marchés publics au niveau fédéral
notamment dans le domaine de la défense
vous avez tous en tête a marché dans le
domaine de l'aéronautique au niveau
fédérer très et américains appris qu'une
exclusion complète de la mp et ce 37
aude l'appliquent en excluant les
secteurs sensibles telles que l'acier de
construction tel site en pennsylvanie le
japon n'est pas plus vertueux ce que
seuls 25 milliards d'euros de marchés
publics sur un total de 570 sont ouverts
aux concurrents étrangers avec en
particulier une exclusion totale dans le
domaine ferroviaire
on peut se demander pourquoi quant à la
chine elle n'est même pas pas partie à
l'accord sur les marchés publics
son offre d'ailleurs d'adhésion pardon a
été rejetée en raison de la faible
ouverture qu'il proposait bref il existe
un déséquilibre manifeste dans ce
domaine entre l'europe et ses
partenaires on arrive parfois des
situations absurdes
c'est le cas de la sphère kovac une
entreprise publique chinoise qui a
reporté sa est évoquée par monsieur le
ministre
en pologne un marché de construction
d'autoroutes en présentant une offre
tarifaire anormalement basse alors même
que ce projet est co financée par des
fonds structurels européens
on est un peu masochiste je pense dans
ces marchés publics
dans ces conditions le prochain conseil
européen doit être l'occasion de
réaffirmer clairement l'attachement de
l'union et de la france à une ouverture
qui table des marchés publics que cette
ouverture soit acquise dans le cadre de
la mp ou d'accords bilatéraux
il importe également pour répandre le
déséquilibre les plus manifestes que
l'union adopte rapidement un outil lui
permettant de se défendre contre les
mesures contre des mesures
protectionnistes d'états tiers et
d'arrêter un désarmement unilatéral
la commission européenne s'est engagée à
proposer mesure législative dans ce sens
avant la fin de l'année nous serons très
attentifs au suivi de cette affaire et
nous veillerons à ce que ces outils
proposés soit ambitieux que nous ne
soyons pas les dindons de la farce de
l'accord amp merci merci
la parole est un madame nicole bricq
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre chers collègues il est pour
le moins étonnant monsieur le ministre
de tenir un débat aujourd'hui pour
préparer un sommet qui vient d'être
reportée et donc ne connais plus
vraiment l'ordre du jour même si on s'en
doute et je vais par avance le préempter
mais c'est vrai que depuis trois ans
s'il n'est pas sûr nous avons appris que
le pire était possible alors si on est
mauvais esprit on se désolera que les
dirigeants européens soient obligés de
repousser les échéances pour tenter de
se mettre d'accord mais si on garde
l'optimisme comme cap
on espérera avec vous tous j'en suis sûr
que ce délai sera mis à profit pour
élaborer un véritable plan de réponse
globale à la crise actuelle car la crise
de l'euro est entré dans sa phase la
plus aiguë depuis que les premières
craintes sur la grèce se sont fait jour
à la fin de l'année 2009
je voudrais rappeler à notre hémicycle
ce que nous a coûté l'indécision
politique en mai 2010 et
nous connaissons ses jours dit ces jours
ci une crise
une situation qui combine à la fois les
caractéristiques de la crise de
septembre octobre 2008 lorsque le marché
interbancaire a pratiquement cessé de
fonctionner et celle du printemps 2010
lorsqu'il était question des conditions
de financement des états de la zone euro
et que ces états ont commencé à diverger
dangereusement
autrement dit la crise de la zone euro
celle de l'indécision politique
essentiellement engendré de risque
potentiellement systémique une contagion
à l'espagne et à l'italie contre
laquelle les outils dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui serait insuffisant et une
crise bancaire qui menacent et
deviendrait inévitable si la contagion à
l'espagne et l'italie se produisait
monsieur le ministre je sais que vous
n'aurez pas réponses à toutes les
questions que je vais vous poser mais je
sais aussi que vous avez à coeur et vous
avez commencé de le faire dans votre
intervention liminaire de clarifier les
enjeux devant le sénat sur le sauvetage
de la zone euro pour que nous
comprenions bien ce dont on parle
je souhaiterais me survit lisent que
vous puissiez nous expliquer ce que
regroupent ce que regroupent par dont
l'effet de levier qui semble être la
solution préférentiels du président de
la république et du gouvernement
français dans les discussions qu'il a
avec notre partenaire allemand effet de
levier dont il est envisagé de doter le
fss quel est le sens de cette formule
quel serait le mécanisme juridique et
quelles seraient les montants en cause
jusqu'à présent la commission des
finances n'a pas reçu de réponse à ses
questions sur la recapitalisation des
banques
quelles sont les options va-t-on vers
une solution européenne
je pense qu'elle est souhaitable ou bien
fera t-on comme en 2008 en sorte que
chaque état gère ses problèmes
pourquoi le recours au fonds de
solidarité pour recapitaliser les
banques fait-il débat alors que cette
option figure
dans l'accord du 21 juillet cela laisse
à penser que cet accord est obsolète
il ne faut pas oublier que cette fois ci
les conséquences de la crise bancaire
sont beaucoup plus grave qu'en 2008 car
les états n'ont plus guère de marge de
manoeuvre
sans compter que le soutien obtenu à
chaud par les banques en 2008 et nous en
avons ici le souvenir sans contrepartie
véritable ne pourra plus se rêve nous
blé dans les mêmes conditions politiques
nous voyons bien que les peuples
grondent et ils ont raison de le faire
dans l'état d'indécision où se trouvent
les décideurs politiques
en tout état de cause la méthode qui
consiste à donner le sentiment d'aller
vers la recapitalisation à reculons
n'est-elle pas la pire puisque l'on voit
les défauts les différents gouvernements
défendre un jour des solutions qu'ils
rejetaient la veille cette attitude nuit
au retour de la confiance et c'est bien
d'une grave crise de confiance dont les
pays sont victimes sur l'organisation du
débat entre européens
je note que le sommet de deauville
lorsque français et allemand ont donné
le sentiment de négliger leur partenaire
a laissé des traces
nous voyons bien par exemple que la
slovaquie hésite encore au moment où on
parle a donné son accord au plan du 21
juillet et il ne faudrait pas que la
démarche qui est un témoignage de la
réalité du tandem franco-allemand de la
démarche de duchamp de la chancelière et
du président de ce week-end soit à
nouveau mal perçue par nos partenaires
alors à plus long terme il est illusoire
de penser que l'on sortira de la crise
sans dégager un accord
ou au moins d'ouvrir une voie ouverte à
une révision du fonctionnement
institutionnel de l'union monétaire
monsieur le ministre je vous ai entendu
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé d'une
fédération économique
je ne sais pas ce que recouvre ce terme
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que une
économie est toujours sous tendu
par une trajectoire budgétaire et par
une stratégie budgétaire qui doit être
consenti ainsi qu'à une mutualisation
des dettes souveraines
on assisterait alors moi c'est ma
conviction profonde
un assouplissement des conditions de
financement des états donc le noeud de
l'afer est quand même très politique
même si c'est à un horizon lointain
ces problèmes doivent être posées je
sais qu'en france c'est difficile de le
faire mais il faut le faire c'est ma
conviction profonde alors évoqué la
fédération budgétaire me conduit à
évoquer en passant la question des
ressources propres
souvent évoquée ici du budget
communautaire et l'idée d'affecter à
l'union le produit de la future taxe sur
les transactions financières alors il
faudrait très claire et lisible sur
l'utilisation que l'on entend faire du
produit de cette taxe car beaucoup se
souviennent qu elle a été imaginé
initialement pour financer l'aide au
développement
et monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé
de 20 ans moi j'ai le souvenir que en
2001 un texte a été voté à l'assemblée
nationale pour créer une transaction sur
les mouvements financiers alors il
faudra évidemment débattre du taux et de
l'assiette c'est bien beau de dire qu'on
est d'accord avec nos partenaires
allemands
mais tant qu'on n'a pas vu les
conditions cet accord reste quand même
largement virtuel et en l'état actuel
qui pourrait se satisfaire d'une taxe
qui ne s'appliquerait pas à l'un l'une
des principales masse de transactions
les dérivés sur devises
c'est une question essentielle c'est le
gros morceau
s'agissant des politiques budgétaires
les gouvernements semblent être les
seuls à ne pas se préoccuper des effets
récessifs de la mise en oeuvre
simultanée de politiques d'austérité
dans les états européens
notre collègue président de la
commission européenne simon sutour a
fait très clairement allusion sur des
ressorts de la croissance alors on
arrive à 1
un moment où ce qui pourrait le faire
des états ne veulent pas et ceux qui
voudraient le faire ne le peuvent pas il
faudra bien sortir de cet état de fait
car j'en suis sûr aussi les marchés
financiers ont bien des défauts mais
j'observe que les analystes leur crainte
essentielle aujourd'hui c'est la
possibilité d'une nouvelle récession
elle est supérieure à la crainte qu'ils
ont qui se cumulent sur les dettes
souveraines et pourquoi une évoque-t-on
jamais la politique monétaire lors des
discussions entre européens alors que
l'on aborde le sujet dans le cadre du
g20
le groupe de travail conjoint assemblée
nationale sénat sur la crise financière
qui avait été créée à l'initiative du
président larcher et du président de
l'assemblée nationale s'est prononcée au
mois de juin
ce n'est pas anciens en faveur de
l'utilisation par le conseil de sa
faculté de formule et je le cite les
orientations générales de politique de
change vis à vis d'autres vis-à-vis des
autres monnaies pourquoi n'en est-il pas
ce week-end on lit dans la presse cna
merkel a souhaité que les traité soit
modifié pour forcer les états endettés à
plus de discipline
que signifie cette proposition alors que
le parlement et les états viennent
paisiblement de se mettre d'accord sur
un taquet gouvernance qui comprend
notamment une réforme du pacte de
stabilité
enfin mes chers collègues pour conclure
je veux croire encore que les roses
européens seront se mettre d'accord pour
repérer les choix politiques s'altère le
poids et l'influencé de l'europe dans le
monde serait durablement atteint si les
européens à se montrer incapable d'être
à la hauteur des enjeux que pèserait une
europe
rappelé à l'ordre par les dirigeants
américains ou par le fmi puisse les
chefs d'état et le gouvernement et de
gouvernement qui se réuniront le 23
octobre avoir cette exigence à l'esprit
soyez en assuré monsieur munissent chers
collègues je crois pouvoir le dire au
nom de tous cette exigence cesser la
nôtre c'est celle de ce sénat
merci merci madame la reporter j'indique
au sénat que la conférence des
présidents a décidé d'attribuer un temps
de parole de huit minutes au porte
parole de chaque groupe politique et de
cinq minutes à la réunion des sénateurs
de figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
le gouvernement répondra ensuite aux
commissions et aux orateurs dans la
suite du débat la parole des orateurs
des groupes
la parole est à madame catherine morin
desailly pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le conseil
européen qui se tiendra prochainement
portera principalement sur la
compétitivité économique de l'union
européenne au regard de ses partenaires
et concurrents commerciaux dans le monde
ainsi que sur la définition de
politiques de croissance pour l'ensemble
de notre continent en dépit d'un ordre
du jour tourner résolument vers l'avenir
la réunion des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ne pourra se permettre de
remettre le présent et abordera
nécessairement les questions pressé par
la certitude du temps
l'europe est parvenu à créer un modèle
qui a vocation à se tirer l'ensemble des
nations la crise a pourtant révélé à
quel point aujourd'hui le centre de
gravité du monde tend à basculer des
rives de l'atlantique vers celle du
pacifique à l'horizon 2050 l'europe ne
représentera plus que 30 % de la
richesse mondiale et 6 % de la
population mondiale dans un quart de
siècle 80% de la croissance mondiale
sera tirée par les pays émergents la
compétition économique qui s'annonce
nous oblige donc à doter l'europe d'ores
et déjà d'une vision stratégique
d'ensemble d'une marche vers la
puissance sans quoi nous serons soumis
soumis au condominium sino-américain
notre continent souffre principalement
d'un double déficit à cet endroit un
déficit en matière d'investissement et
de recherche ainsi qu'un déficit liée à
la volatilité et à la surévaluation de
notre taux de change
cette situation révèle d'autant plus les
failles initial de la zone euro que nous
nous devons de combler au plus tôt une
zone monétaire optimale ne peut
conjuguer à la fois la libre circulation
des capitaux
la parité fixe de son taux de change est
l'indépendance de sa banque centrale
la variable d'ajustement de l'euro est
sans aucun doute sa parité flexible
c'est pourtant celle là même qui révèle
les divergences de compétitivité entre
les états membres
en effet depuis 2008 la parité moyenne
de l'euro par rapport au dollar a été de
1,1
45 notre monnaie est structurellement
appréciée au regard de nos partenaires
commerciaux
si un tel niveau nous protège
relativement des eaux subi des prix des
matières premières et notamment du
pétrole
il nous rend tout simplement moins
compétitif que nos voisins qui bénéfice
de parité mieux ajuster la flexibilité
externe de l'euro est renforcée par le
flou qui existent au coeur des traités
européens
si la répartition des compétences et
claires pour les politiques monétaires
et les politiques fiscales et
budgétaires
la politique du change serait de la
compétence partagée du conseil et de la
bce
or le conseil n'a jamais pris une seule
décision faisant émerger les bauges
d'une véritable politique du change
paneuropéenne cette situation ne peut
plus durer
sans politique de change c'est près du
quart des réserves de devises mondiales
qui sont laissées au bon vouloir des
opportunités mercantiliste de nos
partenaires commerciaux
dans un tel contexte seule l'allemagne
et les pays-bas parviennent à conserver
une balance commerciale positive
d'après les analyses de l'eau fc eu ce
résultat est le fruit d'une
spécialisation historique sur la
production de machines outils au moyen
d'une politique intensive de recrutement
d'ingénieurs formés en europe de l'est
couplé avec une politique de modération
salariale difficilement supporté par la
population
en dehors de ces deux pays nous
observons inéluctablement à l'échelle
nationale l'érosion de notre
compétitivité
notre balance commerciale est
actuellement déficitaire de 75 milliards
d'euros
c'est autant de croissance que nous ne
parvenons pas à capter au profit de nos
entreprises et de nos salariés
le diagnostic est simple à établir nous
n'investissons pas plus assez nous ne
faisons plus assez de recherches nos pme
d'envergure trop modeste en comparaison
de leurs voisines allemands sont
accablés par une fiscalité archaïque et
anti économique
enfin le coût du travail est devenu trop
cher du fait tendues points appliqué par
les 35 heures que par celui des
cotisations sociales pas trop
mal la comparaison se dessine en chine à
elle seule l'entreprise allemande
siemens dépose chaque année l'équivalent
de 60% du nombre de brevets déposés en
france
cette situation est d'autant plus
périlleuse que la crise de la dette
souveraine que traversent de nombreux
états de l'union européenne et notamment
de la zone euro rend les marchés
financiers et les agences de notation
particulièrement sensibles à l'évolution
à venir de nos performances économiques
la solution est connue c'est en renouant
avec la croissance économique que nous
stabiliserons durablement notre
dépendance vis-à-vis des marchés
extérieurs et des marchés financiers
l'europe mes chers collègues on le sait
est à la croisée des chemins
les centristes plaident pour un
fédéralisme européen
l'addition des intérêts particuliers des
états membres ne suffira pas à relever
les défis que la virulence
nous devons poser franchement la
question d'une politique industrielle à
l'échelle de l'union afin de garantir
des emplois et de la croissance à nos
concitoyens un grand besoin d'europe se
fait donc sentir dans tous les domaines
y compris celui de la formation et de la
recherche
il nous faut à la fois créer le cadre
d'une plus grande convergence interne de
nos économies pour mieux faire face à la
compétition mondiale
nous ne pouvons plus nous satisfaire de
réformes à la masse des défis qui sont
désormais les nôtres nous avons
réellement besoin d'un saut qualitatif
institutionnels nous devons progresser
sur le chemin de l'intégration
européenne
cet égard les propositions formulées par
le président de la république et la
chancelière allemande au mois d'août
dernier vont dans le bon sens
il nous faut décidément renouer avec
l'esprit communautaire et l'initiative
franco-allemande de création dans le
cadre du conseil européen d'un
gouvernement économique de la zone euro
est un jalon absolument indispensable
vers une coordination plus grande des
politiques économiques des états membres
de l'union
c'est une entreprise que nous centristes
encourageons avec force la convergence
de nos économies doit l'être aussi
renforcé
par la création d'un socle fiscale comme
un temps moyen de l'assiette consolidé
de l'impôt sur les sociétés à l'échelle
européenne que par la convergence
annoncé des fiscalités française et
allemande
enfin les sénateurs du groupe de l'union
centriste et républicaine propose que la
france se fasse l'avocate de
l'institution d'un trésor européen
abondé par l'ensemble des états membres
afin de financer des investissements
d'avenir nécessaire les mois à venir mes
chers collègues seront donc déterminants
pour l'avenir de l'entreprise européenne
mais aussi pour l'avenir bien sûr de
notre pays
la crise est grave mais c'est en
l'affrontant courageusement directement
à ses racines
sans oublier bien sûr les valeurs
européennes qui sont les nôtres que nous
parviendrons à renouer avec la
croissance
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci la parole est à monsieur michel
guilloux du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
principal sujet du prochain conseil doit
porter sur les moyens de faire face à la
profonde crise financière qui secoue la
zone euro
à la suite des attaques spéculatives des
marchés contre les banques et les
économies des états cette discussion a
été repoussé de quelques jours afin
semble-t-il de pouvoir disposer de
nouvelles conclusions sur la situation
de la grèce et la recapitalisation des
banques
monsieur le ministre c'est donc à ces
questions cruciales que je consacrerai
minutes d'intervention pour vous faire
part des remarques et des propositions
du groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen à l'évidence la profonde crise
financière que subissent les pays
européens avec des conséquences
désastreuses sur leur politique
économique et sociale sonne l'heure de
vérité de la construction européenne
alors que la monnaie unique est
gravement menacée que la zone euro
risquent d'éclater
l'union européenne est la seule zone
économique qui ne se défendent pas
contre la spéculation des marchés sur la
dette publique à travers les différentes
réunions qu'ils ont tenu ces jours ci
les gouvernements et les instances de
l'union européenne ont donné le triste
spectacle
par absence de volonté politique de leur
impuissance à régler la crise de l'euro
à lutter contre la spéculation des
marchés a stoppé une probable contagion
en cascade à la plupart des pays
le dernier exemple en date est la
rencontre entre le président de la
république et la chancelière allemande
qui devait trancher le différend
franco-allemand sur les modalités de
recapitalisation des banques européennes
on se réunit pour décider de ne rien
décider
ou plutôt pour trouver un compromis dont
on ne connaît pas le détail sans doute
pour ne pas mettre nos partenaires
devant le fait accompli et dont les
modalités ne seront précisé que lors du
g20 de la fin du mois où sont la place
et le rôle de l'europe dans tout cela il
serait pourtant urgent de régler la
question de l'intervention publique
face à l'aggravation continue de la
crise qui frappe depuis
fouet les banques de la zone euro
faut-il recapitaliser les banques et de
quelle manière en faisant appel à leurs
moyens propres à ceux des états ou en
utilisant les possibilités offertes par
le fonds européen de stabilité
financière dans la conclusion mon
intervention
j'évoquerai les propositions de mon
groupe sur cette question au lieu de
décider clairement et de façon cohérente
l'union européenne persiste à prendre
dans le désordre des mesures qui
aggravent encore la situation
la façon de tenter de résoudre la crise
grecque est assez des gares éclairante
le plan dit de sauvetage du 21 juillet
est déjà dépassée avant même d'avoir été
adopté par tous les états membres le
parlement allemand la ratifier après de
nombreuses incertitudes le batave
septembre et les slovaques devraient
être aujourd'hui même les derniers à le
faire pourtant l'union européenne le fmi
et la bce étrangle encore un peu plus ce
pays
en retardant et en conditionnant le
versement de la sixième tranche du plan
ces instances totalement sourde aux
colère populaire exige en outre qu'il
accélère son programme de privatisations
des services et des entreprises
publiques qu'elles suppriment 30000
emplois de fonctionnaires qu'il augmente
les impôts pour les couches moyennes et
qu'ils révisent à la baisse
les conventions collectives du secteur
privé rien que cela
ces mesures ont ainsi pour effet
d'asphyxier la croissance en diminuant
les salaires en réduisant la
consommation intérieure et les recettes
fiscales et de nombreux économistes ont
constaté que la grèce était déjà en
récession et n'était même plus en mesure
de ces nouvelles mesures d'hyper
austérité en mesure d'imposer ces
nouvelles mesures d'hyper austérité la
récession grecque risquent ainsi de
contaminer maintenant plusieurs
économies européennes
la succession des plans d'austérité des
plus drastiques n'a pourtant aucune
incidence sur la défiance des marchés
puisque après la grèce et l'espagne les
agences de notation moody's et fitch ont
une nouvelle fois dégradé la note de
l'italie
notre pays
même menacé à cause de l'exposition de
ces banques à travers des prêts
hautement spéculatif à la grèce et
maintenant le démantèlement de la banque
franco belge dexia et le renflouement de
la partie française par l'argent public
de la caisse des dépôts de la banque
postale illustre brutalement combien la
situation devient critique pour la
france car votre gouvernement craint
qu'un surcroît d'endettement ne nous
prive de ce fameux triple a décernée par
des agences de notation au service
exclusif des marchés non décidément face
à la gravité de cette crise il ne faut
plus tergiverser
il faut prendre des mesures radicales
pour empêcher les marchés financiers de
détruire les économies des pays
européens faire preuve de courage
politique pour mettre fin au laxisme de
l'union européenne par rapport au marché
le débat qui a lieu autour de la
recapitalisation des banques est ainsi
fondamental que l'hypothèse de donner la
possibilité au fsf d'emprunter
directement à la banque centrale
européenne ne soit plus taboue montre
combien il devient urgent de changer le
statut de celle ci et de modifier les
traités européens dans ce sens pour
renverser la situation et rendre
possible une maîtrise politique des
états sur des marchés financiers aveugle
et égoïste il faudrait donc
impérativement donner la possibilité aux
états de recourir directement au crédit
très bon marché de la bce
c'est la seule voie pour stimuler
l'économie en élargissant les
investissements productifs utiles aux
populations dans les services publics
l'innovation et la recherche la
formation
c'est pourquoi nous créons nous
préconisons de créer à l'échelle
européenne un fonds de développement
dont la logique différerait de
l'actuelle fff et qui serait financée
par la bce
autorisé à prêter aux états a donné à
des taux d'intérêt très bas pour
encadrer les initiatives purement
spéculatives des marchés
il faudrait également parvenir à un
accord avec nos partenaires européens
permettant d'instituer une taxe
réellement efficace sur les transactions
financières seul ministre hormis une
convergence fiscale avec l'allemagne
uniquement favorable aux entreprises
je doute que votre gouvernement ait
l'intention sinon la volonté de porter
ces mesures au plan européen mais sans
nul doute allez vous me démentir tout à
l'heure sans attendre que le cadre
européen change pour lutter contre la
toute puissance des marchés financiers
vous pourriez déjà prendre quelques
mesures au plan national
je pense en particulier à l'interdiction
permanente des ventes à découvert à la
taxation national des transactions
financières
faut bien commencer à un moment à la
réglementation du droit à créer des
produits dérivés au rétablissement d'un
passeport national pour les fonds
spéculatifs à l'abolition des privilèges
d'auto saisine des agences de notation
ou bien encore à l'arrêt de la cotation
en continu des entreprises monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tels sont
les appréciations dont je souhaitais
vous faire part au nom du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen avant
le prochain conseil européen
merci la parole est maintenant un autre
collègue jean michel baylet du groupe
rdse rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
c'est le président monsieur mines mes
chers collègues à l'issue de la visite
du prêt la république nicolas sarkozy à
la chancelière angela merkel dimanche
dernier à berlin
les deux dirigeants européens se sont
prononcés en faveur d'une
recapitalisation des banques européennes
selon des critères communs ils ont même
souligné à cette occasion en plusieurs
reprises leur unité de vue sur les
différents aspects de la crise
financière mais tout en évitant
soigneusement toute annonce concrète
évoquant des jeux site modifications
importantes aux traités européens allant
dans le sens d'une plus grande
je cite toujours intégration de la zone
euro sans plus de détails
je vous laisse juge or dans la situation
que nous connaissons
mes chers collègues ce ministre
ce sont justement les détails qui
comptent le temps des grandes
déclarations le temps des effets
d'annoncé dépassé bien évidemment chacun
comprendra que c'est tentant d'afficher
au sein du couple franco allemand est
nécessaire notamment parce qu'il s'agit
de rassurer les marchés
sensible au combien depuis plusieurs
mois mais cela signifie t'il réellement
que paris et berlin auraient réussi à
surmonter leurs divergences et en
particulier sur le modus operandi une
photo côte-à-côte ne suffit pas nous le
savons a affiché la réalité d'un
volontarisme politique et il en faut une
volonté politique pour surmonter cette
crise
car chacun sait que nos deux pays
finalement ne s'accorde pas sur le rôle
que doit jouer le fonds européen de
stabilité financière le vice chancelier
allemand et me disait l'économie il
suffit de le lire ou de l'écouter refuse
même un soutien direct des banques par
ce fonds de stabilité financière
par ailleurs la recapitalisation des
banques pose question pour dire les
choses aimablement monsieur le ministre
en effet en 2008 elles ont bénéficié
largement de sommes considérables
d'argent public est certaine on depuis
réalisé des profits importants même nous
pourrions parler d'énormes profits
d'une certaine manière coupable de
beaucoup de nos malheurs elle serait
passé moi l'expression les premières
bougies
il y a quelques semaines elle jugerait
même que tout allait bien et qu'elle
avait réussi les fameux tests les stress
tests haut la main il est vrai que
depuis là le sort malheureux de dexia a
naturellement changer la donne car après
des années d'abandon par les banques de
toutes règles prudentielles des mesures
fortes doivent être prises désormais et
il ya urgence concernant la régulation
et la supervision financière dans les
voyages multiples sont à l'origine de la
crise actuelle
nous réclamons depuis longtemps la
séparation des activités de dépôt et des
activités spéculatives des banques
de même nous appelons de nos voeux la
taxation des transactions financières
la commission européenne a même prendre
des formellement seul ministre vous le
savez encore vu que les autres une
directive en ce sens
certes les taux longs se sont réduits
mais pour une fois nous boudons pas
notre plaisir
quant à la recapitalisation généralisée
des vang n'est-elle pas une manière
d'organiser une faillite ordonnée de la
grèce à ce sujet
les dernières réunions de l'eurogroup
laisse vraiment planer le doute alors
qu'ils sont dans un paquebot
disons le au milieu d'une tempête les 17
ministres semblent faire leur petit
calcul personnel démontre une fois de
plus que la coordination des politiques
économiques en europe n'est toujours pas
d'actualité
et pourtant nous le savons c'est la
seule solution
car sans elle nous ne parviendrons pas
sortir durablement la zone euro de la
crise qu'elle traverse
c'est ce que nous rappelait d'ailleurs
encore hier les deux nouveaux prix nobel
d'économie deux américains pourtant
chantre du libéralisme
depuis longtemps mes chers collègues
l'union européenne a malheureusement
donné le sentiment d'hésiter de douter
voire de rona claire décider les mesures
adoptées l'ont été sous la pression des
circonstances plutôt que dans l'
enthousiasme d'un projet tourné vers
l'avenir
bref sans aucune vision commune il est
temps d'ouvrir les yeux
cette crise n'est pas seulement
financière économique avec ses
conséquences sociales
il s'agit bel et bien d'une crise
confiance politique d'une crise de la
volante d'absence vente et politiques
dont l'issue ne peut donc être que
politique
même si je reconnais qu'il ya eu c'est
vrai quelques avancées et le fsf en est
une mais pour nécessaire qu'il soit
l'accord du 21 juillet apparaît comme
insuffisant limitée et disons le
franchement déjà dépassé car la crise
d'hier n'est plus celle d'aujourd'hui
et finalement tout le problème est là
nous ne cessons d'être en décalage en
retard d'une ou plusieurs batailles et
quand la violence des attaques
spéculatives et brutale et les réponses
exigées économique et politique
finalement ne sont pas à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
faute de gouvernance commune seule une
gouvernance économique et budgétaire
commune faisant cependant à notre
mon et commune peut permettre à l'europe
et à la france de sortir de cette crise
est d'ailleurs unique au monde que de
voir une zone économique commune qui n'a
pas de gouvernance économique et
budgétaire commune et les radicaux sont
convaincus que la seule solution qui
puisse permettre à l'europe de combattre
cette spéculation et de mutualiser les
dettes souveraines et de recourir aux
bons européens
je regrette donc que la rencontre
franco-allemande du mois d'août n'est
pas ouvert cette perspective
plus exactement elle entrouverte avant
de la refermer immédiatement l'adoption
désormais actée dès citec se renforçant
la gouvernance économique
et c'est vrai une avancée puisque je
réclamais gouvernance économique je me
réjouis quand des initiatives sont peu à
ce sens et d'ailleurs je rappelle que
les radicaux la pole est depuis
longtemps de leurs voeux mais c'est
naturellement très insuffisant nous
avons le sentiment que cette gouvernance
s'inspire surtout d'une vision allemande
a minima c'est à lire réduite la
question du déficit
finalement le nouveau pacte de stabilité
de croissance et déséquilibré il
ressemble à une table branlante comme
pied plus court que l'autre c'est en
réalité un parc d'austérité qui mettra
inévitablement la croissance et l'emploi
en berne
voilà nous quittons à l'hémicycle du
sénat merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
science pour la revoir notre site
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
avec comme invité ce soir laurent fabius
cette très bonne fin de journée à tous
à